usted o alguien que usted quiere ha sido
diagnosticada con cáncer de ovario este
vídeo le ayudará a entender la
enfermedad y cómo puede afectarle
y las mujeres tienen dos ovarios estos
se encuentran a ambos lados del útero
los ovarios son la parte del sistema
reproductivo que produce y almacena los
óvulos
y los ovarios también producen las
hormonas estrógeno y progesterona
las dos trompas de falopio están unidas
al útero
después de que un óvulo sale del ovario
pasa a través de una de las trompas
hasta el útero los ovarios se encuentran
cerca del peritoneo el peritoneo es el
revestimiento interno del abdomen que
también cubre la mayor parte de los
órganos del abdomen y la pelvis
la mayoría de los cánceres de ovario
comienzan en la capa externa del ovario
esto se conoce como cáncer de ovario
epitelial el cáncer ocurre cuando las
células crecen fuera de control
las células anormales continúan
dividiéndose y pueden diseminarse a
otras partes del cuerpo
y los tumores de células germinales son
otro tipo de cáncer de ovario se inician
en las células que producen óvulos
y los tumores del estroma son un tercer
tipo comienzan en el tejido de soporte
de los ovarios donde se producen las
hormonas
hay varios factores que pueden aumentar
el riesgo de cáncer de ovario epitelial
un factor de riesgo es la edad la mitad
de los cánceres de ovario ocurren en
mujeres de 63 años o más
la obesidad es otro factor de riesgo las
mujeres con un índice de masa corporal
de 30 o más tienen un riesgo más alto el
riesgo también es mayor para las mujeres
que tienen su primer hijo después de los
35 años o que nunca han tenido un bebé
y recibir terapia hormonal solo con
estrógenos después de la menopausia
puede aumentar el riesgo también los
antecedentes familiares de cáncer de
ovario y otros tipos de cáncer también
puede aumentar el riesgo
es posible que el cáncer de ovario no
presente síntomas tempranos los síntomas
del cáncer de ovario son a menudo vagos
cuando aparecen los síntomas estos
pueden incluir dolor en la pelvis o el
abdomen
gases o hinchazón
sangrado menstrual irregular
sensación de que siempre se necesita
orinar
estreñimiento y dolor de espalda
en la mayoría de los casos estos
síntomas son causados por afecciones que
no son cáncer de ovario
si usted tiene cáncer de ovario el
médico tendrá que determinar los
subtipos del carcinoma ovárico la
calificación y la etapa o progresión de
la enfermedad para ayudar a planificar
su tratamiento
cada calificación se basa en la
diferencia del aspecto de las células
cancerosas en comparación con las
células de ovario normales observadas
bajo un microscopio cuanto mayor sea la
calificación más agresivo es el cáncer
a cada etapa del cáncer de ovario se
basa en que tan lejos se han extendido
las células cancerosas desde donde
empezaron la primera etapa significa que
el cáncer está solo dentro de los
ovarios en la segunda etapa el cáncer se
ha diseminado a otros órganos pero
todavía está dentro de la pelvis en la
etapa 3 el cáncer se ha diseminado más
allá de la pelvis ya sea hacia el
peritoneo los ganglios linfáticos detrás
del peritoneo o hacia ambos la cuarta
etapa significa que el cáncer se ha
diseminado a órganos fuera del peritoneo
si se enfrenta a un diagnóstico de
cáncer de ovario continúe conversando
con su médico y su equipo de atención
del cáncer